Guys, I'm going to ask you to become private investigators at this stage of the list building
process.
So what we're going to do here is now that we've built a list of multiple business owners
paying for Google Ads, Home Advisor, Angie's list, Angie's leads, whatever it's called,
and on and on and on.
Now what we want to do is we want to go and find specific pieces of information about
this business owner so that when the leads come in and we go to make the call, when we
go to make the hook, we have specific information about this individual that's going to give
us, and it's going to increase our chances of getting the deal.
Biggest piece of information that we need is we want the business owner's full name
and cell phone if possible.
Because there's a huge difference when you call in, and let's say you hit a secretary,
or let's say you call them specifically and you call in and you say, Hey, is this the
business owner?
When you call and say, Hey, is this the business owner?
Sounds sketchy.
It sounds scammy.
It sounds salesy.
Okay.
But if you call and you say, Hey, is this Mike?
Sounds way different, right?
You call the secretary and say, Hey, can you pass me over to Mike?
This is Nick.
Sounds way different than, Hey, is the business owner in?
Right?
Totally different.
So what we're going to do in this module, or sorry, this lesson, not module, this specific
lesson is we're going to find specific pieces of information about this business owner.
And some of you guys are going to go, man, this is a lot like to look up.
Yes, it is.
But no one else is willing to do this stuff.
And that's why we're doing it.
So I'm going to have you jump over to the screen with me.
Okay, guys, here is what we're going to do.
I'm going to show you.
And again, as we've talked about this specific city, there wasn't a lot of people paying
for Google ads.
And I just want to show you how we find this information.
So I didn't build out the full list.
I'm still going to go for it simply because it's such low hanging fruit and the position
I'm in.
So it's totally fine.
But I want to show you with this McDowell landscaping old Mike, how we're going to find
information.
Now, the only reason I know it's Mike, going back to the previous videos, because his voicemail
said it was Mike, if it didn't, what we'd have to do is start getting creative.
And so one thing I want the first thing is, as far as finding the business owner's name,
because I think that is super important.
And that's a good starting point is finding their name is I like to check the website,
obviously.
Okay, so go to the website.
I like to check the about page.
And if that that's usually an easy place to find it.
So kind of scan here, that that that that I don't see anything, Mike, I'm going to search.
Yeah, I don't see.
Okay, that's funny.
So I don't see anything on the about section.
But because I knew what the name was, I control after it, which is, you know, you could search
the thing.
And one of the reviews said, you know, Mike right here.
So you can look at their reviews on the website.
But that was the next thing that I was going to say is I like to go to their Google reviews.
And you can really easily read inside the Google reviews.
And people like to act like they know the business owner.
They love acting important, and whatever.
So they'll always say, we hired Mike to expand our patio.
So maybe it's Mike, maybe that's the crew member, I don't know, okay, Mike and the McDowell
landscaping team.
Oh, okay.
So his name is Mike, Mike and his crew.
So we can pretty quickly see that his name is Mike, okay, so Mike McDowell, really simple.
That's how I usually find the business owner name.
Next thing I like to do is I like to find their Facebook page.
So right here, this one was easy.
It just popped up.
So McDowell landscaping, you can tell it's the same, make sure they're in it's the right
city and everything matches up.
So click on this, and I'm just going to drop it over here into the Facebook page.
Okay.
What else?
Facebook, let's see, email, let's grab the email, I didn't see it on the site, nope,
but usually it is on the Facebook page.
So go to the about section, I think, on here, or it's just under the home, yeah, home, look
at that.
And it also says in his email, Mike M, like he's just given it to us, super easy.
This one's very simple.
We've definitely had some other ones that have been more difficult, which I'll go over
here in a moment.
Current position, you can honestly skip that, I might even take that out.
That's kind of where they're ranking, but they weren't ranking, so I don't need that.
Only other thing I would like to add is the business owner Facebook profile.
I think it's very interesting to find their profile, their Facebook profile, and just
learn one or two things about them.
You can learn a lot about someone based on their Facebook profile.
So how do we find the Facebook profile?
Well, first thing you're gonna do is you could just simply search it, okay, so you could
go Mike McDowell, okay, and that's got a lot of options, so I would type in the term landscaping
as well and see if that pulls it up, okay.
Nothing here.
Okay, I'm actually glad this is doing this so I can show you how to find this, okay.
It's not pulling anything up, right?
So here's a really easy way to find the, not an easy way, but a good way, and sometimes
it takes a little bit of work.
One way that you can find the business owner's personal Facebook profile, if they have one,
is I like to go to the Facebook page, okay, and as we know, Facebook pages suck.
They're not fun to look at, no one follows them, whatever, right?
So one thing you can do is you can go to the Facebook page, make sure it is the same one,
and then go down and look at their posts, and I want you to look at people that are
liking their posts, okay.
First of all, they typically are the only ones that like their own posts, so I'm gonna
look for McDowell, nope, okay, so there's no one with the last name McDowell that liked
it, sometimes the mom, the wife, whatever, will like it over and over, but I want to
pay attention to these names, and I'm gonna start looking for commonalities, the people
that keep liking the posts over and over, so I don't see any commonalities yet, but
I'm gonna keep looking, okay, so nothing on this one.
Let's go to the next one, four people like this one, oh, look, there's a Lynn, that looks
like a mom, that looks like a potential mom, grandma, let's go to Lynn McDowell, got the
same last name, we'll check out her profile, if it will load, okay, while that's loading,
I'm gonna keep going, okay, we're gonna look at this one, nope, there's another Lynn McDowell,
that's gotta be a relation, okay, go back to Lynn, now that we're on Lynn, we can go
to her friends, and we can search for Mike, oh, look at that, Mikey boy, there he is,
okay, so now we have Mike, he's the owner at McDowell Landscaping, it's the same page,
we just found it, okay, so that's one of my favorite ways to, let me go right here, boom,
and then I'll just scan through it and add some notes, so I'm like, okay, interesting,
looks like he's on a golf course, so, okay, I like this guy already, I'm kidding, right,
let's see, what else do we know about this guy, let's see, doesn't have a lot on here,
I went to Chandler High School, so he's a local, born and raised, it's not crazy, he's
from Canada, that's interesting, I would probably make a note of that, looks like he was an
estimator at Ace Asphalt, so this is a guy who's come from another company and started
his own, so there may need to be a little bit of sales training with him, there may
need to be, you might need to help him think bigger because he's coming from an employee
mindset, just things to note, I do like to look at their likes section, which tells a
lot, so, you know, American Wire, Aztec, Back the Blue, so he's a big cop guy, yeah, he's
conservative, he's got the Donald Trump stuff, yeah, this is what I like about this stuff,
right, impeached Joe Biden, I mean, you can tell a lot by what he's liked, like, I already
know about this guy, golf, he likes golf, he likes golf, very conservative, Tucker Carlson,
Trump stuff, let's see, Sal Sumo, yeah, I mean, I know, like, not everything, Lion's
Not Sheep, that's a guy to Utah, very conservative guy, like, he's a very, like, proud American,
it's funny because he's from Canada, conservative, and the only reason I say this, I'm not gonna
talk politics, I'm not, I will never do that, but now I kind of know, like, where he stands
on stuff, I know, like, you know, just, you can almost tell what, how somebody is based
on the things that they like on their Facebook page, which is scary, so maybe we should go
check what we're liking on our Facebook pages, but what I'll do is I'll just go in here,
and I'll go to notes, and I'll just put, from Canada, conservative, likes golf, former employee,
okay, and now, here's what's cool, is when I go to call this guy, when leads start coming
in, I know his name is Mike, I know, like, all this stuff about him, right, and you don't
want to be creepy, you don't want to call him, like, yo, that's how you're from Canada,
or you could, I've done that before, and you're like, hey, just so you know, like, before
I call anybody, I noticed you were paying for Home Advisor, so I went and checked you
out, and noticed you're from Canada, I wanted to, like, make sure you were legit, what part
of Canada you're from, like, now the guy's like, oh, this guy knows who I am, like, he's
not just, like, messing with me, so you could play it either way, but guys, it's so, so,
so important that we have these pieces of information, because when you call, and you
know his name is Mike, and you know he's from Canada, and you know these different things
about him, you're gonna know how to talk to him, and, more importantly, you are going
to be able to have that personal connection, because you actually have his name, so what
I want you to do is I want you to finish out your, whatever people, whatever business owners
you had on your list, I want you guys to fill this out completely, and I usually recommend
to have seven to 12 businesses on my list of people paying for ads, if I can help it,
they're all paying for Google ads, in this case, I'm gonna have to go with Home Advisor,
or something else, because there's not really that many people paying for Google ads in
this specific city, and then lastly, what I would say is this, because some of you guys
are gonna be looking at this going, oh my gosh, this is a lot, it is, it is, this is
a lot, and this is a time-consuming activity, so what I want you to be thinking about this
entire time is, how do you get into this, how do you master this, how do you do it well
enough that you could train it, and then what we're gonna do is we're gonna outsource it,
okay, because this isn't something you should be spending your own time on, eventually,
you should be outsourcing this to somebody else, but you have to master it first before
you can outsource it, okay, so once you get really good at finding these names, getting
creative about looking in the reviews, looking on the Facebook pages, doing smart searches,
one last thing I do wanna mention is if you can't find a business owner's name, a good
thing you can do is you can type in McDowell, like this, landscaping, LLC, and I like to
type in BBB, and I like to type in Arizona, okay, like that, and typically it'll pull
up a profile from the BBB, come on baby, let's go, it'll pull up a profile in a lot, and
more often than not, you're gonna find a lot of good information in this if it will load,
okay, so that's another really good resource, I do want this to load because I want you
to see what it is, so you have the Google ad reviews, you have, sorry, the Google reviews,
you have the Facebook reviews, and then this BBC thing I think is really, really powerful,
so this one doesn't have a ton of information on it, it just says, you know, a phone number
which is a BBB phone number, this doesn't say much, but a lot of times, oh, sorry, if
you scroll down it does, I lied, okay, here we go, so if we hadn't found the business
owner name, that BBB smart search helps a lot, you can go down here, it's an LLC, Mr.
Michael Stephen McDowell is the owner, so boom, there you have it folks, there is his
name as well, just some different tools, go ahead, find the information, get the list
built, and let's go get some leads and get a business owner on the hook.